all right we are taking questions for
the first time in 2017 three audience
questions and it will be three staff
answers we will start with it's fitting
from Aaron have you ever actually kept a
New Year's resolution okay I don't
really make new year's resolutions I do
sometimes say to myself on December 31st
or January first okay you know what it's
a it's a clean slate even though it's
totally arbitrary right like what but
there's nothing magical about January
first clean slate
I'm going to commit myself to doing X
more frequently or something like that
but the truth is I'm generally pretty
good at sticking to what it is that I
want to do but I will often also come
across things that I start and decide I
don't actually want to invest more time
into and I'll just sort of leave it and
move on to other things
so I think if the question is am I good
at sticking to resolutions I make I
think generally I am pretty good at it
yeah I mean it is arbitrary to begin
with we're starting a new calendar year
too so to some people that's important
to some people they couldn't care less
about that yeah but I think when you're
making a new year's resolution it has to
be something quite tangible I don't
think frequency is a goal you should be
going for I think it should be concrete
is if I want to accomplish this I want
to you know read this many books I want
to accomplish this at the gym it has to
be very specific well for some I mean
that the gym is where my mind went and
I'm I've not been to my gym yet in 2017
because I've been away but I plan to go
today and I'm wondering will it be
packed and the answer is usually yes I
mean I remember last January it was
packed and then it just sort of starts
to trail off I don't know like I would
that I would even know how to define
goals in the gym I mean for me it's more
just I want to be going more frequently
and if I've generally been going four
times a week I'd like to be going maybe
five times a week or something like that
yeah it is interesting how gyms towards
the end of December will come out with
these promotions to get you to sign up
and the occu into these year-long
contracts yeah you can definitely tell
like the population at the gym will be
three times what it normally is at the
very beginning of January and then by
February it kind of trails off but I
mean if you want to think of you know
Golu maybe something like running a
five-minute mile or you know
bench-pressing 200 pounds whatever it is
yeah
setting some kind of goal in terms of an
accomplishment like that that is
interesting yeah I mean I think in
general with goal-setting
you're going to do better if it's based
around what you're trying to achieve
rather than like in other words most
many of the many of these goals require
focus on the means but you need to have
the end in sight and that's really
what's going to be the motivator or if
there is no motivator that may be what
leads to people not keeping with their
resolution it's all about having a
long-term goal and then coming up with a
bunch of little steps little short-term
goals yeah yeah and some of this seems
obvious but I know a lot of people who
just they can't commit to anything
really they just really have issues
seeing projects through or sticking with
anything it happens a lot with diets
also where people say you know what from
now on I'm doing X or I'm not doing Y
I'm not eating is this I am eating that
and very quickly it just falls apart and
part of that with diet is also you need
something sustainable nothing that is
extreme is going to be sustainable and
part of it being good is that you need
to be able to keep it up it can't be you
know I have lemon water with lemon juice
in it three days a week and then eat
whatever I want four days a week I mean
it is it's crazy you know it has to make
sense a big thing with diet and going to
the gym too is a lot of people take
satisfaction out of telling people that
they're making a goal for themselves
ah and then because they've already
achieved that satisfaction they won't
work to achieve the goal but there's an
opposite to that yes there's the
opposite is that when you publicly state
the goal you have announced it to more
than just yourself and you might feel
more accountable
so there's actually that there's a
school of thought which says you should
publicly a good thing to do with social
media is say what your goal is because
then you've made it public and now even
if no one actually keeps up and checks
up on you you might feel like I said I
was going to do this publicly I'm going
to do it yeah I'm glad you brought that
up because there is a feeling that
you're obliged to do something once
you've told everyone about it but it
really just said it depends on the
person I would say it because I think a
lot of people do get satisfaction out of
just telling people they're going to do
and then don't follow through with it oh
it's okay if social media has taught us
anything is that people get a lot of
satisfaction merely from saying things
and then not actually doing anything my
Facebook feed is evidence of that